but you see somebody would then go well
actually what you're saying this in your
you know you in a very comfortable
career you are a man of privilege or
white man of course you would say these
things because you've never been
oppressed there's a huge amount of
assumptions in that statement yes yeah I
see that I have a successful career
[Laughter]
often the accusation of privilege comes
with all kinds of assumptions and what
I've noticed is that people who peddle
this idea tend to be from very
upper-middle class backgrounds it seems
to be a very bourgeois concern identity
politics at the moment I'm not saying in
all cases but certainly the most
prominent vocal elements of the liberal
left have double-barrelled names tend to
I mean they're the books that are being
published about this stuff where people
are desperate for victimhood tend to be
quite well-off people who people who
talk about their holidays in the
Pyrenees when they were young and and
all of this kind of stuff so I don't
know where the assumption that I'm
privileged is privileged for me of
course people face homophobia and racism
and all this stuff and we need to stand
up against that but above all else what
privilege comes from money from contacts
from opportunity from nepotism from all
of the stuff that middle-class people
have only 7% of this country are
educated to private schools but they're
disproportionately represented in the
law in the media in journalism in all of
the major in politics all of the major
positions so really if we wanted to just
to sort this out societally we would
address that imbalance so I would never
say to someone you're privileged because
you were white it doesn't make any it
doesn't make any sense I mean when
Monroe bergdorf the labor activist said
that you can still be homeless and have
white privilege that is incredibly
insulting thing to say from someone who
is so privileged so upper middle class
and has had all these benefits but as an
ethnic minority and trans person that
all of a sudden the the the victim
hierarchy shifts and so someone who's
homeless is suddenly more is privileged
or potentially privileged I mean this is
a nonsense so I think we have to think
in terms of class I think if you're not
thinking in terms of class consciousness
you can't really high self identify was
left in my view or there were a lot of
people on the Left do seem to think that
by by focusing solely and and must
emphasize I'm not
saying that tackling racism at
homophobia and sexism isn't important
it's key to what I believe in what I'm
saying is it is often done at the
expense of class concerns now there was
a would be one thing if it was if we
would covering everything but that
doesn't appear to be certainly my
reading of it that is not how how things
are playing out in a practical sense so
if you say to me well my argument is
undermined by the fact that I'm white
well or the fact that I'm male how do we
know that I haven't been disadvantaged
in in other ways how do you know I mean
you don't curious about that because we
were talking about just before we
started actually and I asked you if
you're gay because I read that you did a
show oh the way you talked partly about
that and I'm curious that you haven't
brought that up in defense of your right
to speak
which I find interesting because that is
the instinct we most of us now have
isn't it to kind of go where I'm
oppressed as well then a formality
I think it's irrelevant I think it would
be irrelevant if I were a black gay
female I I think the argument is what
matter I think this okay so this is
where I think a lot of the liberal left
are going wrong it's they've forgotten
how to argue we don't have critical
thinking at the heart of schooling
anymore I used to teach critical
thinking at a level it's really really
key and it's important the first thing
you learn from a critical thinking
course is as soon as you attack the
person or not the argument you've lost
it's an ad hominem attack so anyone who
in invokes
your race your gender your sexuality has
already lost the argument